[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Галичина
Львів]
Ми трохи дисонуємо із переважною більшістю бізнес-середовищ у Львові.
Тобто ми собі звикли, що бізнес — це чуваки, які собі працюють
і, як Саша Буль співає:
[Юрко Назарук
Співвласник холдингу емоцій !FEST]
сауни, ресторани, дерибан майна...
Воно все десь там поєднується.
А ми не ходимо
в сауни з прокурорами.
І воно інше.
Якщо ти бачиш,
що є якась «інакшість»,
приходять люди, які теж так думають.
Це наш «творчий безлад».
Та чого «безлад»?
Навпаки — все організовано.
Ну «творчий ахтунг» тоді,
чи як то назвається?
На цьому поверсі у нас арт-частина:
піар, дизайн, відеопродакшн,
продакшн і проєкт-менеджмент.
Ми тут якраз придумуємо
і робимо усю естетику
компаній, будинків, школи, авіації,
ресторанів, і взагалі холдингу, і фестивалів.
В нас є диктат грошей і концепції.
Тому ми нічого не відпускаємо,
все тут самі робимо.
Тут є прямий хід до мене в кабінет.
Я вважаю, що мої мають
мати першочерговий вхід,
незалежно від того,
що там відбувається.
Бо коли заходити туди,
то там офіційна приймальня,
там питають: «Ви до кого? Куди?».
А тут можна відкрити вхід
і залізти в люк, коли захочеш.
Я Дмитра знав ще з університетських часів.
Коли я зробив перший заклад «Культ»,
то ми там познайомились з Андрієм.
Тобто ми не є друзями з дитинства,
разом не вчились, не бойові побратими.
Перший раз Юрка побачив,
коли він робив в закладі «Культ» у Львові.
[Андрій Худо
Співвласник холдингу емоцій !FEST]
Це було в підвалі філармонії.
Вдруге ми уже зустрілися предметно,
щоб обговорити ідеї «Криївки».
І за дві години взагалі про все домовилися:
ідея, цінності та решта.
Віра тоді була шалена!
Шалена така, що ми тоді
на всі гроші ризикували.
— Насправді логіка...
— Папки — це все бутафорія.
Логіка всього, що ми тут робили,
що FESTrepublic — це місто.
Тому у нас поділено на квартали.
Кожен відділ — це вулиця,
а кожен працівник і кожен стіл —
неначе номер будинку.
Ми мали офіс на Лемківській вулиці.
Там 1000 квадратних метрів,
де ми просто не вміщалися.
Ми розуміли, що ми вперлися просторово:
добрали людей, команду.
І тому ми пішли у цю інвестицію —
у великий FESTrepublic,
де 2 гектари землі та
14000 квадратних метрів,
які дають можливість, при певній ідеї,
акселерувати її тут.
Ми коли розповідаємо, що FEST — успішна історія,
то я би завжди підкреслював, що це важка праця.
Нема речей, які просто зробити.
Як на мене, це чиста енергія!
Тобто приходять люди, що її мають,
вона додається і йде вверх!
Ходімо у Видавництво Старого Лева
Це один із наших проектів, хоч ми всі любимо проекти,
проте цей — наша гордість.
Гордість усіх українців.
Коли ми заходили у видавництво,
то всі казали, що ми придурки.
Це ж видавництво української книги —
найбільш неперспективна історія,
що лиш могла тоді бути.
Втім сьогодні ми можемо
казати твердо:
по-перше, це хороший бізнес,
це отетерінно цікава робота
і що це асболютно
успішна історія для України.
Тут є книжки, які ми продали як контент закордон.
В Південній Кореї діти читають
про кротенят Тараса Прохаська з Франківська.
І ось це — круто!
— Доброго дня.
— Ха-ха, що — холодно на вулиці?
Арт-об'єкт, як завжди.
Я думав на металолом здавати,
а Юра каже: «Та, ну!»
Coffee Mission — кавовий хаб.
Початок нашого бізнесу, який, сподіваюся,
винесе, в позитивному сенсі, в світ.
Це кавова лабораторія,
де проводяться капінги.
Багато кроків, які ми робимо,
можуть бути місцями попсовими.
Втім, є суть:
наприклад, у нас є «Копальня кави»,
яка, думаю, входить у топ-5 в світі
кав'ярень, де продають каву.
Тобто ту кількість, яку ми смажимо...
в Україні — це 100%,  але я думаю, що й у Європі ми не знайдемо місць,
що продають такі об'єми кави.
І ми зрозуміли, що нам
просто треба пірнати вглиб,
і пробувати виходити
у такі більш нішеві проекти.
Нам видається, що
майбутнє за спеціалізацією.
А тому логіка цього проекту — це з'єднати
виробника зі споживачем напряму.
Ці всі штуки потребують інвестицій і часу віддачі.
Так як Андрій каже, що це довга гра.
Ти не можеш інвестувати та
за два місяці відбити !FEST Coffee Mission.
Тому що такий проект
передбачає зміну культури пиття.
Зараз ми не в одному такому проекті,
який змінює культуру
споживання, продажів, носіння одягу,
культуру того, що українське може бути добре.
Ми будували з самого початку
ціннісну компанію.
Вона відчутна в кожному проекті.
Коли ми розвивались,
то компанія дійшла до певного рівня,
коли вже дві тисячі працівників,
а то й більше чи менше,
то ти починаєш впливати
на громадську думку.
І очевидно, що тоді йдеться про те,
щоб Україна була кращою.
І кайф приватної освіти в тому,
що будь-які інновації можна
впроваджувати швидше.
Фактично миттєво: ми сьогодні придумали — завтра можемо реалізовувати.
Тобто більшість людей, які прийшли до нас працювати в школу,
дивилися на нас, як на цілковитих недоумків.
Ми ж з нуля зробили її за 2,5 місяці.
«Школа вільних і небайдужих»
вона називається.
Тут, бачите, уже попахує
таким же безладом, як і на !FEST.
Ойойой.
І оцей момент, коли я заходжу,
а там стоїть 100 батьків...
В жодному проекті я не мав такого трепету.
Зробити найпонтовішу школу в місті?
Ну, це ж занадто легко!
Я скажу чесно: я не хочу,
щоб моя дитина в такій вчилася.
Але вона буде понтова, всі будуть ходити, їздитимуть дорогі машини.
І тому ми поставили собі за ціль —
вище середнього.
І коли ми знаємо, що є ТОП,
то ми не можемо бути найдорожчими.
По-перше, бо ми хочемо зробити більше.
По-друге, ми хочемо,
аби до нас ходив середній клас.
Нема цілі зробити найкращу школу.
Ціль — щоб всі школи були прикольні!
Я не хочу, щоб ті діти, в тому місті були отетерінні!
Я хочу, щоб усі діти були отетерінні!
Бо моя дитина буде жити серед них.
І тоді починаєш ставити
перед собою інші кейси.
Ми поставили задачу:
5 шкіл в місті, 100 шкіл в Україні,
і будувати схему всю спочатку.
Щоб воно мало великий
внесок у всю освіту.
— А в тебе є фейсбук?
— Так.
— Відколи?
Тут наш.
Я коли вперше зібрав батьків,
то їм було нецікаво, хто що робить,
кому вони віддають.
Я чесно оце все розповів, більше того:
ми ж готові були до того,
що в нас нема офіційної документації.
І я так зарядився, думаю: «Кайф!»
Як завжди: підпільна школа,
без документів, оце драйв!
Але так склалося, що нам їх видали.
За день, до того ж, самі.
Бо ми так наробили кіпішу,
що губернатор сам зателефонував:
— Ви ж там школу відкриваєте?
— Так, відкриваємо.
— А у вас є документи?
— Та нє, а навіщо?
— Ну, бо ми ж їх видаєм!
— Ну, видавайте.
Отак і видали.
Все в світі, що не змінилося —
змінилося завдяки бізнесу.
Від літаків, велосипедів,
до лампочок і всього решти.
Люди хотіли зробити щось: заробити на цьому, подбати про себе,
про свою сім'ю і світ, зрештою!
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Максим Завалля, Олексій Панченко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Сценаристка
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Музика
YEYO]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]